revenons au service national pour
l'instant privilèges des jeunes gens
j'espère que ça le restera
combien sont ils à le faire l'équpe ont
réservé de cette année obligatoire donné
pour la défense de la france voici
quelques témoignages reconnu recueillis
par l'établissement cinématographique
des armées
actuellement plus de 280 milles appelé
participe de la défense de la france
au départ on aurait tendance à croire
qu'il ya pas mal de difficultés que
c'est très difficile en fin de compte on
se rend compte que c'est assez
spectaculaire mais pas tellement
difficile et toujours rien n'assure
conclu par cadeaux
enfin il faut pas être un tarzan pour
être là il faut presque autant mais il
ya une certaine appréhension face à et
quand on a franchi l'obstacle que dans
la frangine autre âge dit finalement
installée du tout
parcours collectif tout le monde en fait
quoi tout le monde m'a duché et prenez
le cul et luis ocana photos allaient
trouver là ce n'est pas ce qu'on va tous
voilà allez ici saluer ici ici
quelle place dans cette course le match
aura lieu le père yves le premier la
deuxième toul rosières base aérienne 136
15% d appeler font leur service national
dans l'armée de l'air
ici à la base vous êtes conducteurs de
chiens sales et laser de l'affectation
n'en suis pas un hasard si moi qui
demandait à faire le travail
vous entendez bien avec le chien ça
reste un bon souvenir dans six villes
aux oreilles
pour le travail de détecteurs oui c'est
très intéressant
poursuivez la piste 59 57 % des appelés
sont dans la marine nationale
ils ont constitue le quart de l'effectif
j'avais décidé de faire mon salut dans
la marine pensé que c'était peut-être là
qu'on avait la possibilité d'avoir un
rôle à intéressant jouer puisque vont
tourner en mer bon on a chacun notre
rôle
il faut que chacun y participe si on le
bateau il marche que si tout le monde y
met du sien il n'y a pas de problème
74% servent dans l'armée de terre
un tiers sert une arme dans une unité de
combat l'ennemi se situe au nord au delà
de cette lunette
il a laissé quelques éléments
retardateurs à notre mission enfin de
bons ça sera de s'installer sur cette
lisière façon nord la situation amis
nous avons la deuxième section qui en
appui sur notre droite
soir abc pour un tiers sont dans les
services et assure la vie courante des
unités tête qui tourne tu vas te pousser
la db en 15 21 ans au dessus de saint
jean sur tout
voilà la vie de ces jeunes conscrits
dangereusement à vous présenter nos
invités